taken by oconor drops it down deep for the nice
blistering Pace looking for a redirect could not
get it vasileski hugg that far post and it's LIF
it up on Al Here Comes Devonte still working right
ahead as the ab getting a sh slams it down deep
air chasing now is bance husin to kale at the
points that one hop through McKinnon rolls into
the circle Mo picks it up sends it down deep and
a redirect off the side of the net B at shushin
who suddenly found himself all alone just couldn't
stretch out quite enough he understood that he
said everything happens for a reason and he's
glad that he's here oh absolutely that's a great
Point kg fit off to kale lar we'll talk more about
that momentarily now T looks it down deep save
by vasileski that one got through and it's sent
up an out giving chases Asam off roll screen it's
pushed aside by goria Asam turns it fires goria a
funky save having the big cat back between the
pipes is huge for the lightning as they look to
Counterattack and Braden Point works it down the
wing tried to send it for oh my goodness he he did
get a piece of that puck goria had to make a stop
that was out of midair incredible fed off Byrum
Off the Bench walks in and shoots save rebound
off the side in the net from NuSkin almost was
one look at Hegel go well he scored 30 goals last
year this year he's pace for 40 now you know how
he's doing it left Winger on that Top Line picks
it right out of midair G knocks that right off ble
will cycle it off points finds COV shot save gorv
he was reading that that was coming a three-goal
game allowed his team to crawl his way back in
M with his shot wide of the N byro tried to get
there and slapped up and out racing forward Joe
hson it's a two on one Johansson shoots and scores
Ryan Johansson elex to hold on to it himself and
he rips it home for his eighth goal of the season
the ABS are on top one nothing and look at big
number 12 get loose comes in turn over at the Blue
Line right there toar on headman then he slips
look how B Ryan Johansson wants to pass wants
to pass the defenseman plays it perfect and Johan
says well you're going to give me this much room
to take a look far left Simon going to absolutely
snipe love the super Mo look and right through the
seven Hall we said on that wrap around the other
night against Calgary fired wide in the net by
Tampa we thought you had to shoot we didn't think
you could do that in terms of the wrap around with
the bat K he said I'm not sure I did either that
was so good off the glass by Tes radish will glove
it down and direct it right back in k couldn't
quite get there so here comes the ABS forth line
with a re shot save by vasileski whated the return
from oconor couldn't quite get it lightning played
that one pretty darn well and it's set ahead by
Watson Caleb Jones recognized the ABS looking
for numbers again here comes one down the slot
back hand it's Sav by baseli 943 to go period
one the ABS on top one nothing I think Olson
had ke r on the backhand breakway just couldn't
get that pass over stamp goes down the boards
shoots save rebound save there is Josh Manson
check by point it comes on up but didn't stride
it's druin into the Zone Jonathan druin showing
the speed druin shoots just one of the net that
was almost carbon copy of what we saw the other
night was that every how about this speed M coming
down the wall looked like shades of McKinnon taken
away watch out fired ahead K's got a break away
Del the SL he'll shoot what a save by Goran oh
my goodness with a one- nothing lead and Alexander
goria off the cheater he's bringing his aame here
tonight here's Point found himself free in the
slot Point turns shoots and it's blocked by
Tatar Mar will pick it up but he's on the Move
kale Mar has tar with him kale trying to find
tar oh my God shot SC royan Johansson cleans
up after tar was absolutely Rob by vasileski
for Joe Hanson it's his second goal of the game
Mak a terrific recognition we talk about good
defense there's tar blocking the shot now kale
goes wide so tar can catch up and the puck comes
right back to kale throws it again and that might
have been one of the wildest split saves I've seen
baseski make and Johansson buries it block shot
kale comes wide to Tar cat is up here's a break
off the defenseman stick back to K back toes it
off for McKinnon who's back in his SP face it's
Gale looking down the slot and he lost the handle
Tampa getting a little bit tired on the PK long
shot there score it was deflected kale M dials it
up from way down and the ABS have taken a three
nothing lead it definitely hit something on the
way in well the ABS were Tic tacking in around
motion I thought four they're going a long
time ago getting a shot here and once again
Val thein in front is there any chance that went
off big number 13 as it comes down and absolutely
I'm giving that one to Val here's the money
look watch the stick right oh maybe not that
might have slid right in knuckle bottom right
hand corner hope there's no damage there watch
out here comes Paul through the circle shoots
and a save by goria and he denies the second
opportunity the man's fine
and he appears to be fine
it comes for headman long re shot deflected
save rebound score Michael Aon is fifth of
the year did not give up on the play since
the apps went up three to nothing and just
watch the opportunities on the rebounds the
deflection and here comes that rebound and he
kind of whiffs it which is how it kind of flies
by gor because he's expecting something hard to
come on that glove area and it just slid right
under the bottom pad nothing you can do there
but that's probably the sixth grade A scoring
chance by Colorado the play was determined to
be offside no goal and there you go BR HCK again
coming through with eyes like a hawk that one view
you can see bit did not hold his left skate
graned it scoots it back to the point 23 to
go in the five on three one timer off the post
by mckin the outside of the post we're on that
far side one look right in the Wheelhouse McKinnon
unloads right through the screen it's just on the
outside of the post yeah at the mullet coming
up on Thursday then back to back at the Ducks
and the Kings Saturday and Sunday fire ahead R
Celli shoots and scores wow Anthony Celli with
a perfect feed from headman able to split the D
right along the ice with a shot and he's made it
a 3-1 game with 30.9 seconds left the last minute
of the period I talked about staying strong and
there it is Celli right up the middle from Hond
and eventually what else can gorgi have do he's
been left hung out to try here the ABS haven't
scored on their multiple power plays and they're
right on the ice through the five Celli golly Josh
Manson just racked up two dudes that was awesome
vintage Manson McKinnon cross I shot save ASI 123
to go here period number three as still on top
31 going to choin a wrecking crew he's just
been fantastic off the glass kept in that's
an onside play by danan radish sends it in
front turn around shot save gorv that was
really good to the near side Gran had a man
tied up that puck is loose to McKinnon he'll
race for it naan McKinnon gives it off for
NuSkin Big B got it on somebody throws it
in the net and scores out of CH and if not go
to make it 4-1 the ABS will put this one away
on his 10th of the Season very unselfish
mckinon just wanted to find a lineate with
eight goals and four assists in that time what
a nice play by McKinnon knew he had nowhere to
go Val throws it around hitman's coming over
and he puts it centered cup and that puts it
away for the ABS and we know how important
Final 5 seconds will pick off here at ball
Arena and the Colorado Avalanche have defeated
the Tampa Bay Lightning by a score of 4 to one